[Music]
um so I think what's so fascinating
about the working world right now is
that it is in complete flux
um everything's been thrown up into the
air and quite frankly we're not 100 sure
where all the pieces are going to land
and I think a lot of things are on the
table people are questioning you know do
we need a corporate headquarters or not
you know that's being debated you know
what is the role of
um uh remote work you know
um if it's possible why should I come to
the office I've heard stories of people
picking up the phone and calling their
their CEOs calling their bosses and
saying ah it's so fantastic you know our
family's living the dream we've we've
moved to Florida you know and the
company's like but we're in Kansas you
know and they're like I know it's just
wonderful we've always wanted to live in
Florida and now we can and like nobody
asked do you mind if we moved to Florida
um and and so I think a lot of companies
are like do we say anything is that a
problem but I we wanted everybody to
come back to the office
um and the answer is we are kind of have
to wait and see and so when you ask what
should companies be asking themselves I
think they have to put everything on the
table and ask themselves what is the
future of work one of the things that I
think will happen is there's just going
to be more flexibility so in the past uh
sort of pre-ar comfort with uh remote
work you know you would have to ask
permission if I can work from home next
Thursday and I think what's going to
happen in the future is people are going
to pick up the phone and send an email
and saying hey I'm just going to work
from home today and everything will be
fine like everybody everybody will be
fine with that
um but I'm I I think everything's on the
table and those discussions have to
happen
um and and you cannot dig your heels and
say well this is the way it used to be
and this is the way it's going to stay
it's just not going to work out well